three national leaders on a mission to
solve how the EU will plug the post
brexit funding gap should it be done via
cutbacks redeployment of finances or
should the Richer member states pay
higher contributions Germany's
Chancellor Angela Merkel has already
made it clear that Berlin is prepared to
increase its membership fee but the
Netherlands and Austria are against the
idea of rich countries paying more what
we do not want is an ever-increasing
burden on the net contributors because
the net contributors already make a very
very large contribution Britain's
departure from the EU will lead to a
multi-billion euro funding shortfall the
Netherlands say only by making cutbacks
can more money be found for mutually
important issues like security and
immigration for May we've contributed
large sums and for good reasons but we
can't allow this to increase now Angela
Merkel has made one contentious proposal
to save money by attaching conditions to
funding this would mean countries like
Hungary and Poland accepting more
refugees critics say this measure would
be unjust then VHD if we combine funding
with solving immigration issues who will
carry the cost not the government it's
the citizens and I don't know if that's
the best solution jean-claude Juncker
president of the EU Commission is taking
a pragmatic approach EU nations will
have to pull together he says but it
seems there's a long way to go before
that will happen
you